My name is Kirill Grouchnikov, I've
been at Google for the last five years,
and I do client work,
UI work, on the Play store.
>> Okay, awesome, and
what do you like about it?
>> Well, I always liked writing code and
seeing pixels light up on the screen.
So this is the Play App,
Google Play App.
Starting from top to bottom, we have
the search box, and we have these,
what we call quick links,
to go to various subsections of the app,
and of the store.
And then we have different content here,
so we have clusters of cards.
We have this,
we call a banner, that gets you
into some other place in the app.
You can go into the details
page of a certain item,
let's say Angry Birds Telepods, and
this is what we're showing here,
kind of the mix of information
that the developer has provided.
We have the video of the app.
Then we have the short description
of the app's screenshots.
Then we have the user provided content,
reviews and ratings of that app.
A little bit more related content.
And then here, a couple of links.
And you can go also
from the details page.
You can start the install process.
This is the permissions.
And then you go and accept them.
And it starts.
So you can see over here,
it starts installing it.
So the students have been learning
about text views, image views, buttons.
Can you point out a couple
of those in apps?
>> Yeah, so back to the cards,
if we look at this Star Wars Rebels.
So the card itself is
an extension of a view group.
But it can be as simple as a extension
of our elegant layout, and
then we have this
thumbnail is an image view.
Then we have this,
Star Wars Rebel is a text view that
goes to a maximum of two lines.
Rating bar is, well, rating bar.
The free is text view, and
the overflow dots is an image view with
a source set to a certain PNG
that looks like three dots,
and then the same for
the quick links, so
it is a relative layout with
the image view on the left.
And then the text view in single line
mode going to right of that image view,
and extending however much it needs.
And it has its background
set to a certain drawable that has
a green background with rounded corners.
So essentially, as you say, it boils
down to taking these very basic building
blocks, text views, image views,
sometimes rating bar,
progress bar, spinner,
check box, radio button.
And combining them based on what your
design shows on a particular screen.
>> Yeah, that's so cool because the
students are learning this in their very
first lesson of Android and you're using
this every day in the Google Play app.
You mentioned working with a designer.
So can you describe what
that process is like?
>> So,
it starts from the product people, and
then it goes into
discussions with design and
engineering on what are the screen
surf we are talking about and
how, hopefully, already at
that point of the design site,
we start thinking about how we'd adapt
to smaller screens, to larger screens.
And after that,
we do these kind of iterations
on putting something on the screen, and
start validating the overall approach.
Because sometimes you have a static
mark or maybe a motion mark
from after effects or
whatever tools the designers are using.
And you see it on your desktop screen,
and then you put it on the phone and
it feels quite different.
Because you have a smaller screen.
Or because it's a tight interaction,
or maybe because you
are depending on all these great big
images, but the network is slow.
And so, you start with this screen that
five seconds doesn't display anything.
And so, hopefully throw out
this iteratic process, where.
We put something on the screen,
not necessarily pixel perfect,
then we can go back into the product
level discussions and see, okay,
what do we need to tweak?
>> So, for developers who don't
have a designer to work with,
do you have suggestions on what they
can do to make their app look better?
>> I would suggest to
going to the website for
material design and get acquainted.
Not necessarily with the finer
parts of motion arcs or
all those interpolators, but
focus on the bigger picture.
So to have consistent grade
across the entire app,
what we call key lines or
what the design calls key lines.
Vertical and horizontal, where elements
align to certain visual rhythm
and they don't feel just
randomly thrown onto the screen.
And so you have your toolbar.
You have,
maybe other parts of your Chrome,
like the navigation
elements on your screen.
And then you have the content itself,
so it's great when it all aligns to
the same grid, and you have a little
bit of margins on the sides.
And things are not too
close to each other.
Then you have typography.
Which is a great way to visually
convey the relative importance
of different things.
So if you talk about something like
inbox, or Gmail, or an email app.
So if everything has the same
typographical language.
If everything is the same color,
the same size and the same style,
then it's not really easy to scan it.
So maybe you would want
the RQ make the sender.
A little bit bigger, like the sender
name, or maybe the title,
or the first few words of
the subject to be bold.
And that would allow the user
to more quickly scan.
It depends, once again, on your content.
But I wouldn't recommend necessarily
going with too many styles,
or too many sizes.
Three, four styles used
consistently across
multiple screens allow the user to kind
of get, even on a subconscious level.
To get kind of a picture of how
to get things done in your app,
and necessarily fight to understand
where the information is that he or
she is looking for.
And the last thing, colors.
Use a little bit of,
especially with material.
It kind of leans toward using big
splashes of saturated colors,
which looks great, especially if it goes
into the status bar on Lollipop devices.
Identify what we call the accent
colors and primary colors.
Identify a couple of colors.
And use them to, kind of, you know,
to style the chrome of your app,
so like status bar, action bar, maybe
a little bit in the navigation drawer.
And use and highlight so X sends for
the floating action button or
maybe to draw attention to
a certain,very important element,
what you consider a very
important element.
And I think these three
go along way towards
emphasizing a little bit more
the visual style of the app.
And of course,
if you have an opportunity to team up
with a designer, that's always great.